hello
and welcome to today's webinar
translating insights into better
outcomes
announcing the new kaiseek human exome
integrated solution
my name is brian dugan i'm an associate
director of global product manager of
the genomics group
at kyogen
over the last few years kyogen which is
obviously well known
in the sample sample prep side and our
over the last few years caiden which is
known for its sample prep solutions
and for its bioinformatics solutions has
built a powerful
uh next-gen sequencing portfolio
um the the the excellent sequencing
portfolio that kaizen has built has been
largely
on amplicon-based technologies
specifically the underpinning
technologies things of like single
primer extension
which allows us to do one primary at a
time as a target across the genome
chemistries that are robust for
enriching
in multiple different facets in multiple
different analytes including dna
rna methylation and more as well as
adding things like unique molecular
indices and unique dual indices
and so all in all kaiju has been able to
put together a comprehensive solution
for many researchers
to be able to look at all of these
different analytes with this technology
but as we move on to the future we need
we know that there's a need to be able
to
to to essentially to be able to do
large-scale genomics
to do that kaijen is announcing our new
kaiseek exome solution
and what we're really bringing here is
now the addition of two different things
into this technology portfolio
the first is the addition of hybrid
capture as a way to enrich for the
genome
and the second is really pairing the the
wet bench side
with the in silico side to bring about
integrated solutions
so now we're single primer extension and
primer-based solutions we're really
focused on
you know small panels or even
medium-sized panels
now we're able to do genome-wide or
ultra-large panels
that allow us to look at things not just
from one specific area or small area of
the genome
but really expanding onto many megabases
and covering a tremendous amount of real
estate and be able to look at things
not just in cancer but look at focused
inherited panels
and really be able to see all of the
exons simultaneously
now part of this is driven right because
we know that there's a number of trends
that are going on
in the market and overall the cost of
sequencing
is rapidly decreasing and in fact just
this year
it even decreased even more as the price
of some of the noticeable
flow sales has decreased considerably
this drop of pricing
in this now access greater
democratization
uh to sequencing capacity allows larger
and more complex experiments to be done
and so with the fact that now there are
more high throughput sequencers than
ever before
that's that costs are lower than they've
ever been though for
it now makes exome an even more uh um
a bigger opportunity here to be able to
look at that and to do more
experiments than ever before using a
genome-wide
panel but one of the challenges here
with doing exome sequencing is not the
amount of data that you can generate
but the fact that the variance and the
interpretation of those variants
is still a clear and present challenge
and a bottleneck that we will discuss
later on in the presentation
now as i announce archivistic human
exome
it's a true solution to detect
pathogenic variants with confidence
ease and efficiency and there are three
main points here to to really just to
start off discussing
the first is is that while getting this
comprehensive
detection of disease-causing variants
we actually have a solution that will
help reduce your sequencing cost per
sample by up to 50 percent
our solution is a single day automation
compatible workflow
that is specifically built with scalend
it's also built with the ability to go
from essentially any type of sample as
well and we'll talk about the
differences between using blood samples
tissue samples and circulating cell free
dna
and finally as we go to the second part
of the presentation we'll talk about the
way that the wet bench side
integrates seamlessly into the
bioinformatics side
allowing you to take a variant file and
go through
comprehensive interpretation to reduce
your overall temp uh
turnaround time from sample to insight
so first let's talk about the first
point
so one of the the biggest challenges
when doing exome sequencing and i talked
about it previously in the current
trends
it's not so much the cost of the panels
themselves as it is the cost of
sequencing
and when you look at the cost of
sequencing you can see that it varies
tremendously
right now up until recently a whole
human genome cost about
a little under a thousand dollars in
sequencing reagents
and that's dropped by about 75
but exome sequencing itself and the
ability to sequence deeper than you
would with the genome
right has always been considerably
cheaper
but the cost is really associated with
two different things
specifically with how large the size of
the panel is and how efficient is the
panel
and so looking at our chiastic human exo
and just a brief
uh you know discussion here is here you
look at our panel here our kaiser human
exome
which essentially um with 95 of the
sequencing at 30x generates about 8
gigabases of data
when we look at two competing suppliers
you see that the amount of sequencing
data to get that same coverage
is at 10 gigabases and 15 gigabases
all of this with higher um whole fold
and 80 penalties
so all in all what you what you see is
that all these things together
lead to your ability to actually
multiplex
more on a chi c human exome panel with
less sequencing cost
now we'll show you about how this
results and how this actually
impacts variant detection in some
following slides
but you can see here that just on on a
next week two by 150 run
then you can do almost you know 40 to
up to 50 percent more samples right at
a single run this gives you the
flexibility to take either more samples
and to sequence them simultaneously
or to sequence deeper on some precious
samples
let's talk about the kit so the kit as i
said is a single day workflow
it's automation compatible and it really
allows you to go from
sample to to to data
the first step as in many exome
workflows
is using is doing library preparation so
here we show our kaiseek fx dna library
prep kit
the kaise fx dna library prep kit is
actually
a enzymatic based library prep
that allows you to do library prep
without any type of mechanical shearing
that can take under three and a half
hours
all of this is currently automated
automatable on multiple platforms
the next step in this is now the
enrichment in the kaiser human exum kit
now the advantages here is that there's
a number of different
uh hybridizations and times that you can
actually take
it really based on on what you're
looking for with the hybridizations that
are can be
you know very very quick to overnight
ones you have flexibility to essentially
to slot into your current workflow
or be able to speed it up into what
might be the some of the fastest
uh of solutions on the market
after that it's simple sequencing on the
illumina platform and then analysis
using our
our kaijan clc genomics workbench and
kaijin clinical insight solution
but as i said in the in the previous
slide
that while we show the chi-c fx dna
library prep kit
which is enzymatic fragmentation based
many customers have different
preferences on how they choose exome
sequencing
and so to really to be able to meet the
demands of many of these different types
of customers
we have other kits as well that are
compatible with different types of
approaches or different types of samples
the kaise ultra library input library
prep
kit is a solution that allows you to use
existing kovarus workflows
that's flexible from a single nanogram
up to 500 nanograms of input
and all while using this physical
sharing method
now the other solution now in looking at
circulating cell free dna
is our kinetic cf dna library prep kit
this actually adds uh the kyasic ultra
low input kit
plus our cayenne circulating nucleic
acid kit
so essentially all you need to do is
have your tube
full of with blood and then it's an
isolation and a library enrichment in a
single box
again this is compatible with uh with
covaris or physical shearing methods
right and it is a very flexible um
solution to get you right into
enrichment
but as i said the the workflows for
hybridization as we move into that step
are quite flexible
now there are many different types of
hybridizations that are possible with
the chia seek exo
exo kit the first is as quick as a 30
minute hybridization
the longest is the typical overnight
hybridization
right and there are times in between
from 90 minutes to two hours to four
hours
but what i'm showing here on the right
side is a figure that shows the targeted
bases
and the x fold of mean coverage and what
you see here is that the
without a doubt his hybridization time
will have an effect on how the
representation of bases happens
but when you look at a comparison
between a four-hour hybridization and
overnight hybridization specifically
you can see there's not a significant
difference in terms of performance
and what this means is this allows you
to still do a single day workflow
without having to do an entire overnight
hybridization which can speed up your
solutions here
without the overnight hybridization you
can simply on the same day
go right into your sequencing uh
reaction and onto the onto the sequencer
and actually start that up to eight
hours faster
now there's different types of
hybridizations and if you need to do
things ultra
fast you can always go down to 30
minutes with hybridization as well
so all in all it's a highly flexible
solution to really to meet any customer
need
now in terms of performance here right
when we talk about
the fact that this kit really provides
provides uncompromised performance
and has equivalent performance on target
coverage regardless of whether it's a
single or multiplex hybridization and
capture
so there are different solutions out
there to allow you to do a single
library or
poll or multiple libraries per pool but
what you see here on the figure
figure on the right again looking at x
gold of mean coverage
there's essentially no difference
between doing a single library in a pool
and eight libraries in a pool all in all
this is this really just shows that
these pools
are highly efficient in ligating and
pulling down
from the libraries
now the other thing to think about and i
brought up cfdna earlier
is is that cfdna can be quite
challenging and this is specifically
because dna
in serum and plasma is degrading
and so here we took a look as a
comparison between looking at high
quality genomic dna
and different ffpes i'm sorry this is
i'm sorry talk about ffpe
uh and i'll get into cfdna in the next
slide but here looking at
ffpe and the different qualities
so here in the comparison between
between genomic dna
and ffpe dims of 3.5 4.4 to 4.7
obviously the high quality genomic dna
is going to provide you the highest
quality in terms of representation
of what you get from your targeted basis
but when we look at
more samples that are more degraded
right from as low as 20 nanograms here
right starting from this this lowest
level of the 3.5 dead
is that you can see that right below the
dark blue line
is that all three dims really perform
essentially simultaneously
really just overall so you don't have a
tremendous amount of drop
off even from looking at high quality
dna or different types of quality
from ffpe all in all right this
shows you is is that the library prep
process plus the enrichment solution
will offer you a robust solution for the
most challenging samples
now here is the slide discussing cfdna
and again
cfdna is this is similar in terms of
ffpe
maybe perhaps not having as much
degradation but certainly
fragment sizes of dna are much smaller
than high molecular weight dna that you
would derive from cells
but you can see here again when doing a
comparison of 50 nanograms of high
quality genomic dna
to either 10 nanograms or 20 nanograms
of cfdna
but there's essentially no difference
between either one of those cfdna plots
now again here it's just only slightly
less
performs as well than genomic dna but
again
the enrichment that you will have and
the amount of coverage that average
coverage that you will have across the
targeted bases
is essentially commensurate and so if
you look at
10 nanograms and 20 nanograms as well
right on the left side now
if i look up to 40x coverage i see 90
plus percent of the of the target bases
are covered in a minimum of 40x
if i if i sequence to to about 80x
average
in terms of the exo so this again
shows that the the the quality of the
total solution
will deliver you high quality sequencing
results from some of the most
challenging samples
now another aspect here which is often
important to look at is representation
or base representation
now typically genomes themselves should
be balanced in terms of tc and at
content
but at times you can tell that certain
uh
certain solutions whether it's in the
library prep or the probes
may have certain sort of biases towards
certain type certain compositions here
and you can look at the percentage of gc
as a real good indicator of this
and what we're showing here with the
chiastic human exome is that if you look
at the midpoint here of
this graph the percentage of gc of the
target is that you want to come close in
terms of this heat map of right in the
middle right about 50
as the genome is but when you look at
comparing solutions that are in the
market
you can see that representation can rise
and fall
you know really significantly you know
much farther than 50 percent
so again coming back to the performance
of the kaiser human exome
our exome performs in a really balanced
way giving you equal representation
across the genome
which will leads to higher quality calls
better representation and lower amounts
of drop out in regions of the genome
to further illustrate this we chose a
gene
adat38a3 and we looked at this because
of its high gc content
it's specifically challenging to
sequence because it has approximately 65
to 70 percent gc content
and here's a comparison on the right
side of two different pileups
one on the top is the chi c cuban exo
and the other is from another supplier
and when you look at this just visually
on the right side you can see
that that both both sets essentially
cover this entire
uh entire gene but the reality is that
pulling this down is not really possible
or is more possible with the chi sequin
exome
you can see here from the lines is that
that there is total coverage
across this entire gene even even
despite the effect of
this extremely high gc content and so
now this was done with an average
coverage of about 100x coverage
and 100 of the bases of this targeted
region
are actually covered and it's actually
covered at an extremely high rate about
89.3
x coverage is overall was covered
so when you think about this and going
back to the representation and the
importance of this
this leads you again to it's just
further proof
that by with our solution from library
prop to our probes and the total
solution with that
is that you get an efficient solution to
deliver high quality
high representative uh um data uh
that will allow you to make the best
calls
now what's often being asked now of
exome sequencing is not just
calling snvs and being able to call
structural variants such as copy number
variation
and the kind seek solution actually
works seamlessly with our kaijin clc
genomics workbench
that has a pre-configured workflow
directly in there
and so we wanted to do was show our
ability to do cmv detection
using two known standards horizon
reference standard
dna hd 753 that has known cnbs in met
and then mcn and what you can see here
is that you can
essentially that the probes are designed
to be able to cover this region
right but this analysis allows you then
to be able to go through it to
specifically look at
from the read pile up and look at the
probes to be able to tell
if something if there is a copy number
variation
so again it's not just calling single
variance
right or single nucleotide variance but
also doing structural variants such as c
and b's
now what's what is you know exome
sequencing now has been used for
almost a decade from uh you know 10
years ago
um the first probe sets that really were
released
on the first of technologies on the
illumina technologies and solid
technologies
right and it has evolved and over that
time what we have seen
is is certainly changes in standards and
things that need to be called to be
reported
the first of those really to be called
out is obviously the acmg-59
right genes that are specifically
important to be covered and that acmg
uh really has put a specific emphasis on
and so in doing an analysis of how we
perform
in these genes we did a number of exomes
at 100x average coverages
and what i'm showing here on the left is
how each of the base coverages at 100x
are covered from a percentage point of
view on the left side you see total
bases that are covered
from what at 1x the total bases that are
covered in all the acmg 59 genes is
99.66
of the bases if i go all the way up to
40x coverage
96.3 percent of the bases are covered
and so again whether you're at 1x or 40x
makes a significant difference in your
ability to call variables right 40x
especially for many of these these genes
which are
associated with inherited disease 4dx is
sufficient to call many different
variants and so to have that high
percentage now again
leads to higher quality results and
varying calls
on the right side though the other thing
to consider is end-to-end coverage
it's not just single bases here and
while you're not going to have a
significant amount of drop
out right if you're covering 99 or 96
it's also important to understand from
structural variation analysis
how you're able to do for an end-to-end
basis
the table on the right side here right
is showing this
so again at 100x average coverage on the
exo
we looked at what is the end-to-end
coverage of each of these acmg 59 at 20
x
and at 20 x 98.2 of the bases are
covered
continuously there's no breaks in it and
a single base pair break right is all
that
essentially it takes to drop that out
but
again here also looking at 40x coverage
95 of the bases are completely
continuous
so again the reeds are unbroken
the coverage is unbroken and delivering
you those high quality results
but the question always comes back well
how does this actually affect things
when i go to call variants
and so when we look at the kaiseek exome
and its workflow with our both our
our clc genomics workbench and pairing
it with our
kaijen clinical insights we looked at
the hdmd database and specifically
looking at the size of our panel
compared to other providers
and our ability to detect known hdmd
disease disease mutations
now going back to the value that i
talked about earlier here
you can see here that the chisel human
exo is smaller than other providers that
are out there
by a few megabases you know really at a
minimum
but in spite of that
the chiastic human exome actually will
cover and pull down and detect
more disease-causing mutations in hcmd
even given its smaller size
and when you compare that to other
solutions which have larger sizes
and will cost more to run right the fact
that you can still
with a more efficient panel pull down
more mutations gives you a higher
confidence in the fact that the areas
that are most relevant to human disease
are being covered
pulled down and actually analyzed
because it's not just about the probes
it's not just about the sequencing
it's also about the analysis that goes
along with it
it shows clearly that we don't also miss
or we miss
less h of the hdmd of disease variants
that are out there as well
and so again you know looking at the the
combined value of
higher calling of hdmd variants and
lower costs
this is a highly efficient solution that
you can implement in your lab
now one of the other things to consider
here is that when looking at
exome sequencing you know you know to
look at hcmg at a variant level
is is certainly something that many
people do but so much of exome
sequencing is being done in a way
where it impacts disease and it impacts
you know people who potentially have
this disease and research
into these diseases and so when looking
at hcmd variants what we do is we what
we did is put in a did an analysis and
putting these into buckets
based on the diseases that are known
and just a small subgroup of some of
them and so we associate it with
cancer-associated diseases
uh inherited cancer associated diseases
specifically
things like hearing loss cystic fibrosis
taste sacs marfan and then oi
as well and what you have here is that
even compared to other solutions
that are out there on the market the
increased detection of the hgm
very hdmd variant is important but when
it is directly associated with diseases
and linked to those things
you're actually going to find more and i
i bring this because essentially this is
the
this is why exome sequencing is really
able to be done right is it's
for biomarker discovery or it's also to
be able to look at things at your
genomic level for a broad basis to
understand potential on some
some diseases and there really is no
better solution that's out there
you know even despite the smaller size
compared to other solutions
to be able to pull down these you know
important variants
so all in all right with the size the
efficiency the automatable solution
and being able to deliver insights here
in some of these key areas
you can see this is a true end-to-end
highly valuable solution
but as we move into the next part right
and i'll briefly touch on this
is that we know that the bottleneck here
is really is not just on the front end
but it's everything that i've talked
about with data analysis and variant
interpretation
and so we're about to move into our
second part of the presentation
that will that were uh rupert yip also
from kaiogen from our kaijan digital
insights team
will walk you through how you go through
um the fast q files after they're
generated
and go through our analysis with our
kaijun clc genomics workbench
all the way through kaizen clinical
insights um for kaiseek
but as i close up and i transition over
to rupert
rupert's uh time here i just again
talk about the main bullet points first
kite the new
kaise human exome is a comprehensive
solution
for detection of disease-causing
variants with potentially up to fifty
percent reduction in sequencing cost per
sample
it's a robust single day automation
compatible workflow
that will fit almost all of your needs
do you prefer
non-mechanical shearing versus
mechanical shearing
do you prefer to have it automated or
not automated
right all of these things are capable
with our different kissing solutions
and now rupert i'll leave it to ripper
to talk about our rapid data analysis
solutions
and how we're able to deliver you know
really a best in class
and and sample to insight solution for
doing
human excellence i want to thank you for
your time
and i'll now pass it off to rupert
thanks brian for that excellent overview
of the
high seek exome what i'm going to talk
about now is
how to take that high quality data that
is coming off
of the film vibration
and how one would analyze separate
detected variants coming off of those x
samples
so as uh as brian had alluded some of
the challenges
with uh analyzing an exome
has to do with the volume of data that
comes
off of synaxon we're talking somewhere
between fifty thousand to hundreds of
thousands of variants that you need to
save through
um as well some of the callers the
the algorithms that are used to do the
text variants are not
accurately detecting some of those
variants
and sometimes it requires multiple now
i believe detect uh relevant
mutations as well with uh interpreting
human exomes once you've identified
candidate variants you need to identify
you need to refer to multiple annotation
databases to get
some information about those detected
variants
um and then of course you don't want to
manually do the due diligence on all
hundred thousand so you want to have a
reliable way
to sit down to only the interesting
variants to
say more then finally
once you do identify those variants
interests
you need to look them up in all those
different databases read the
publications
and adhere to society guidelines on how
to
properly interpret those mutations
so today i'll talk about the analysis
and interpretation
portion of that workflow uh
that includes things such as variant
triage experimentation
and i'll talk a bit about some of the
challenges with computational speed and
accuracy of varying stalling as well as
the pipeline output and then finally
once you've identified those variants
how to kind of triage those variants
some of the algorithms that are used to
do the expert curated content
that's associated with those annotations
and well as how
prioritized salisbury
so first i'll talk about the analysis
which is a detection
of the mutations this is primarily
the workflow that comes off of the
sequencers where you've got
the raw fastq files um and our solution
um allows you to then send those fast
two files to a
cloud-based analysis platform
some of our customers have their own
bioinformatics scheme and has a homebrew
bioinformatics pipeline to generate
style there are of course virtual off
the shelf solutions that are available
and then the fourth hydrogen has its own
solution called the kaiogen clc solution
and all of them as long as they generate
a bcf
with verse 4.0 or above
will it will be compatible with
our interpretation solution
so in the past these pipelines to
generate ccf file has been quite
cumbersome and required i.t
knowledge where you have to perform that
analysis through command line
the kyogen clc solution prevents an
elegant
user-friendly interface that allows
a biologist really with minimal i.t
training
to be able to kick off these types of
analysis
and one of the beauties of the kyogen
solution
it is purpose-built for the kaise exome
wherein we have a specific plug-in
designed
explicitly for the kaiseek exome
but you can see here that in
one of the plugins that you can select
from the clc workbench
is the iseq panel
plugin and with that plugin allows you
to with a wizard allows you to walk
through the setup
of how you want to configure and
parameterize the analysis
of your ic exome data
once you've analyzed that data we have a
variety of tools that allow you to
quickly review the results
and pilots including a genome browser
more importantly we have powerful
visuals ethics sort of
the way all full the data comes off of
the
sequencer so that you ensure high
quality data
is used in the final interpretation
results
next i'll talk about the the
interpretation workflow and that
includes the variant triaging
verification what exactly is variant
triage
well if you're working with exomes and
particularly with genomes
where you could have anywhere up to
millions of mutations obviously you
don't want to do the manual curation of
all millions
you want to try and sift through out of
those millions down to the tens or the
handfuls
that are likely causing the
phenotype or disease of interest and so
the ways
people typically narrow down the
variance of interest
is through a series of some selection
criteria or filter criteria
where you remove the common variants out
of the
raw data and of those remove those that
have no obvious effect on proteins
and then of those remove those that are
not
um in the correct context of the disease
that you're looking at so for example if
you're looking for
a human homozygous or heterozygous type
of mutation or if you're looking for
a de novo or a particular mode of
inheritance type of mutation
that allows you to sort of iterate on
your hypothesis
of the genotype of the disease of
interest
and then based on those remaining
variants i
want to say those remaining variants
show me those
that have any relationship direct or
indirect
with the disease or the phenotype that
i'm presented with
so those are the ones that you want to
do the deep dive and manual curation on
and so having this variant fiat
workflow allows you to quickly go from
millions down to the tens
so the traditional method of manual
curation is fairly
might start off with the raw vcf file
that has
like i said up to a million variants
you may even have a trio of them if
you're doing a trio analysis
and from there you might want to
have additional metadata such as
phenotype
pedigree information to describe the
relationship between those
various samples and then from there you
want to identify if there are slight
spaces
that are found in databases such as
slinvar
and whether you want to make sure that
your
variant curation solid
society guidelines such as acmg
from there you might want to see whether
the
mutation of interest has certain rarity
among a
population healthy so you go to
databases to snowmad
genomes and then you might want to look
up additional annotations
film browser uh from there you might
want to look up in silico predictors so
you'll use tools such as mutation paper
add and then finally when you do
have mutations that satisfy all
of your criteria you might want to go
ahead
and go into pubmed to look up those
papers and then
ultimately or even google scholar and
then finally
going into um reading those papers
so it's a fairly tedious process with
qci translational
we automate that process again you start
off with those various pcf files
and you have the metadata you can
combine that
into the platform and the platform will
do the variant triaging
to quickly go from the millions to the
sample sends
that information is fed into the
knowledge base where you can ask those
relationships direct or indirect between
the remaining variants and the disease
or phenotype of interest
to quickly generate a list of annotated
variants with relevant
and then finally you can export the
edited variants into a text file for
follow-up
reporting so
we get our knowledge into the knowledge
base from
several sources they come from public
databases
from licensed databases as well as
kaijin proprietary databases
we then apply that knowledge across
society guidelines
so that it's computed in a consistent
fashion
as well as applying um
integral predictors and so our content
is really updated
to basis the guidelines are refreshed on
a quarterly basis
we have we draw from over 40 different
based sources and we have been doing
this for
over 20 years where we employ over 200
mds and phds
who do nothing but read thousands of
articles a month and manually enter that
information
the qci platform really is a platform
that allows
the streamline aggregation of samples
so you can do sample inventory and
management of those samples
on the platform it allows you to do that
variant triage
prioritization that i mentioned once
it's prioritized those variants it then
computes
a variant classification within the
context
of the phenotype and disease of interest
and then combines the analytics tools
with the knowledge
that's generated
so with that i'm just going to quickly
dive into a quick demo
to see how all of those workflows are
executed in the application
so once you log into
qci kaion clinical insights interpret
you're presented with lists of analysis
that you created
and to look at an analysis you simply
select
any of these to upload samples you go to
the sample
list page that shows all the samples
you've ever uploaded as well as the
sample management inventory here to
upload samples fairly straightforward
you click upload sample
and then you can some upload sample
so i'm going to go ahead and select a
kaisek exome
example here oops let me just move this
out of the way
and then just submit and it uploads the
device into our servers
it does a validation to make sure that
that vcf file is
client effects parts it
once that sample is up there you can go
ahead and create an analysis with that
sample
we'll go ahead and select a previously
created filter
setting
and then select uploaded sample and i
can click and drag that in there
if i have other sample metadata asset
here
i can continue if i have
a clinical symptom so i can go ahead and
enter that here as well
i'm just going to go ahead
read it
i'll go ahead and
um and then to take a look at the the
analysis
i've already pre-created one here we can
go ahead and take a look at
how the annotations work
so here you have an overview
this is what we call the variant this
table
these are the variants that are um the
list of prioritized variants from a
starting list of over
38 000 variants and we were able to
filter down to 100 variants and of those
100
we prioritize based on pathogenesis
to understand what filters were used and
you can click on the pencil icon here to
open up
and you can see that we filtered
confidence filter is really looking for
high quality variants variants that are
for example a fred score of 20 or
greater
i didn't select this but if i selected
this a minimum read depth
genotype quality so forth
and also say i'm looking at variance
with a rare
of less justice here if i wanted to
um and then the biological context
filter really is looking for
any um uh disease
any variance of the 2264
that are related to hearing loss in this
particular
test but i could have selected any
biological experiment
i want to add additional filters i click
the add filter to add more so for
example to predict the deleterious
filter allows me to select variants that
are
computed as pathogenic like that's
what's according to acmg guidelines or
are listed within the
hgmd clinvar or central md database
or are associated with gain of function
or
loss of
so those are the various filters that
you can use to quickly go down from the
hundreds of thousands down to the tens
if you want to do a deep dive on a
particular variant so
this has already prioritized these
variants based on pathogenicity i can
double click to go into this um
to explore this variant a little more so
this is the deeper dive that i'm talking
about
and the system had computed this variant
as pathogenic and here are the criteria
that were triggered
the acmg criteria that were triggered
there was about five
criteria that were triggered and
the evidence to support the triggering
triggering of the ps4 is listed here so
i can go in and take a look at the
evidence by clicking on it
and it showed that there were four
papers that triggered that
ps4 really is identifying any cases
that were consistent with this mutation
and this disease
and so you can see that there's this
paper published this year
um that describes this particular
mutation
the l 1160 deletion
associated with congenital hyperthyroid
hypothyroidism
for example um and so
you can read that paper or you can read
sort of like a quick summary of what
this
uh the relationship
if you believe that paper and and you
believe
the evidence you can just leave it alone
or but if you don't believe the evidence
you can x this out
and it will recompute the classification
based on the absence of that evidence
you can then um you know based on your
own
expertise you may decide that this is
you know maybe more of a likely
pathogenic versus a likely pathogenic
depending on how your lab likes to
interpret these and then set the
assessment
but you always have this evidence that
is
clearly transparent how we suited
us the variant details pain really
more details about the variance
variant there's
yep if you're not familiar with the gene
you can click on the gene reviews of the
genetics home reference link
if you have um that particular
bam file open in igb you can click on
this to open up
genome browser within igv to view the
pileups
or you can just go back to the clc tool
type syllabus you want
the effect on protein is fairly useful
it allows you to see where
in the gene this mutation exists
so in this particular example it
exists in this so each rectangle
represents an exon so
it seems to be showing up in this
particular exon of the gene
this yellow area represents the
functional domain of that
protein and it shows that this mutation
occurs in the functional domain of
protein and these red dots represent
other
pathogenic knowledge-based concepts
clinical cases from other laboratories
can be found in clinical spaces section
and so in this particular example there
is one
example of this mutation found in the
hcmd database
the rarity in general population allows
you to look at the frequency
of this particular allele in a general
population so
you can refer to the steel frequency
community
nomad database for the exxon variant
server
that information here as well as
thousand genomes
reported functional impact really looks
at
in silicon predictions of the impacts of
this particular mutation and so you can
look up cad scores
mutation taster max end for splice
thing as well as gene splicer bff
as well and yet again another genome
browser option
which is if you have bam and sex files
available
you can point to those and and look at
it
there's also the bibliography of this
particular mutation if you want to
to read all the papers that are
associated with this mutation
there's 20 there's some 40 24 papers
or references associated with this
mutation but if you're only interested
in clinical cases you can just fix and
see the clinical faces or just
filter for only functional studies so
statistics
zero in reference
that's fairly straightforward in how you
sort of
upload and create an analysis use
guide
so now to finish up in summary really
the
the qci solution for
the kaisek exome is designed to
streamline that interpretation
going quickly from the hundreds of
thousands down to the handful
so that you can focus your effort on
only those handfuls
and it's really a solution designed to
address those challenges of significant
amount of data that's generated
from sequencing effort
and it standardizes the way in which you
can interpret these variants
as we adhere to the acmg
criteria guidelines um
and allows you while i've shown an
example of just a singleton you can
certainly do
trio analysis with this uh platform
as well as a case cohort analysis
with these tools it allows you to
quickly do that manual curation
that due diligence to look across
multiple annotations
from various databases to quickly
understand the effects
of the impact of that mutation on this
sample it allows you to identify the
relationships between the disease
and the gene or the even variance
interest
and it quickly allows you to scan across
various databases sub standardized
across
guidelines
and with that i conclude this portion of
the
presentation and
open it up to questions